a little over 14 months ago Daniel Ponce
de Leon
he suffered a life-threatening injury he
was struck in the head by a batted ball
and he needed emergency brain surgery he
was hit in the right temple and he was
pitching in triple-a they said he had a
fracture to his skull he had bleeding on
the brain spent a week in intensive care
after surgery inactive for three months
I don't know if he was thinking about
his baseball career at the time but then
he gets called up and he throws seven
no-hit innings last night and Daniel
joins us now Daniel thanks for joining
us how do you feel today good I'm doing
okay and was pretty episode heartwarming
story was a feel-good story last night
how did you feel when you first got on
the mound last night I felt pretty calm
and focused and you know it's
comfortable when you look up and you see
Yaya over there dropping down signs for
you take me back 14 months ago if I if I
said you know what 14 months from now
you're gonna be on the mound and
flirting with a no-hitter what would you
have said
after you suffered that injury if you
see told me I would be on the mound yeah
I would believe you but flirting was a
no-hitter I don't know about that I've
never done that in my career but you
know every time you go out you always
hope to throw a no-hitter a perfect game
any doubts along the way with rehab
getting back into baseball no not at all
well just I was just sitting there
waiting once once my school healed I
knew it was off to the races what did
you remember about that night when you
were hit with that comebacker I remember
pretty much everything up to surgery and
then after the next couple of days is
when I finally came to how do you get
past being gun-shy with the crack of the
bat now I don't know what kind of hurdle
mental or physical that would be for you
but did you have any of that last night
when you heard the ball hit the bat not
that hit the bat that often but
no III would say I got through it was
just safe safe and God and his plan for
what he has for me but did you have
anybody who told you that maybe you
shouldn't be on the mound anymore nope
none of the doctors said anything like
that after they saw how quickly I got
better there they were optimistic
did you lobby to stay in last night
right when I came out in the seventh
inning I knew I was pretty deep in pitch
count and I knew my bat was up and I
obviously have not been good at the
plate this year so I and it was a one
run game so I knew it was time and I was
it was the right decision
more nervous at the plate or on the
mound last night 100% to play I I am NOT
a good hitter and yeah facing a guy
throwing 95 plus miles an hour never fun
what your teammates say to you when you
came out they all hug me and tell me
good job smiled and they're the best how
many text messages phone messages did
you receive after your performance at
least over 200 myself buzz and some
people over my wife songs buzzing my dad
phones buzzing so yeah it's probably
gone for a couple of days that's pretty
cool
did you have a favorite player pitcher
growing up player wise growing up when I
was it was Mike Piazza and pitcher wise
would be Pedro Martinez well you know
pitch like Pedro you look a little
different than Pedro out there but
that's not not a bad guy to have as
somebody looked up to a Daniel yeah
wonderful have you met him by the way
Pedro yeah I spoke to him last night for
the first time and that was the only
time I ever talked to him wait so MLB
tonight and then all of a sudden they
said you know Pedro is on the phone
you're like give me that phone it was a
MOV Network and they did a little
interview and I I was kind of stars
oh that's cool well are you looking
forward to facing anybody in particular
no I haven't really looked that far into
it's just I've pretty much taken one
eight at a time that's the way to
approach it and when's your next start
I'm not sure you haven't been told
anything but I'll be ready to go within
the next five days to pitch again well
good luck and great performance last
night great story Thank You Daniel and
we appreciate your time thank you Daniel
Ponce de Leon the Cardinal starting
pitcher that's a great name I'm waiting
for the Fountain of Youth you know at
age 26 he's you know reclaimed like who
discovers young yeah rediscovered like
you have a fountain with the siyoung
coming out of it yes boy I didn't play
baseball you you guys played and pitched
in stuff like that do they teach you
when you're learning to be a pitcher how
to defend yourself is that not something
even putting a pitchers head never ever
practiced it right ever efforts my coach
showed me a little bit about you know
the follow-through and how you prefer
you to end up so that you can feel the
ground but yeah but that's that's far
different than a line drive off an
aluminum bat that could be coming at
your head you'll find some pitchers who
want you to hit the ball are ready to
field the ball Maddux was brilliant at
this Greg Maddux I don't know how many
Gold Gloves he won but he wanted you to
get yourself out because why you know
why throw eight pitches to get you to
ground out or strike you out why not try
to throw two or three to get you to hit
the pitch I want you to hit and get
yourself out so Maddux was always ready
to field and a lot of these guys they
spend so much time and energy on the
delivery and not the follow-through of
where you land and you'll land off to
the side of the mound whereas if you
watch Maddux when he threw he was ready
to receive a ground ball yes he yeah I
remember you know you're supposed to
sort of bring your leg around and be
ready in a stance but by the time you
got rid of the ball it felt like it was
already right back on top of you in a
way and so it's more something that you
just chose not to think about rather
than practice you know I'd rather not
think about a comebacker I remember and
I was pitching in
in this was after college and I'm
pitching in a league in Cincinnati and
there were guys who played minor league
baseball guys who got called up to the
majors and I remember throwing a
fastball and this guy hit a liner over
my head I swear to god I can still hear
it go by my head he hit it so like I
didn't fool him with anything
he was a already a professional hitter
and I just kept thinking if he had hit
it like two feet lower I can't stop my
heart he had hit just this bullet and I
didn't even see it I heard it and I
remember facing pitchers where I didn't
even see the ball the left-hander who
eventually pitched in the in hi minors I
remember he threw a ball and I I just
remember that you know the UMP gone
Stara and I said it sounded like his
strike like I'm saying to myself that
sounded like a strike I didn't see it it
was that like oh it was just a blur but
that's a great story
you know Congrats to him and you know
trying to come back from that just to
get on the mound after you know you have
that you get hit in the temple intensive
care 14 months later for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]